in Cologne it is disconcertingly quiet
an industrial city brought to an uneasy
silence but in the shadow of its vast
Cathedral we find a wedding party on
this couple special day no parents no
reception and only two guests who double
as the photographer's standing two
metres apart it's really strange because
my family have to dare to stay home they
couldn't come because we're only allowed
to bring our witnesses who have to stay
2 meter behind us when walking to the
City Hall so this is really crazy but
we're really happy that we can get
married and they didn't cancel at all
Germany was prepared it's got an
abundant hospitals at restricted problem
areas early on and tracked down carriers
at this hospital near Frankfurt they
quickly installed a drive-through test
center Germany's aiming to do half a
million tests a week many times more
than the UK or France there is another
factor here Germany has one of the
world's oldest populations
it seems the elderly have been generally
resilient until now
last year a museum seemed fair humor
partying what we are seeing a very young
patients more than half of our patients
around a 40 but the percentage of old
people who are now getting sick is
increasing and among the elderly the
virus develops fast back in Cologne this
laboratory has gone from processing a
hundred tests per day to now doing eight
times that it aims to step up even
further to analyse 2,000 tests per day
all in the hunt for some kind of answer
dealing with this is a little bit like
chess you have to understand your
opponent in this car in this situation
the virus to see what is the virus doing
how is the virus spreading and how are
the people that are infected what also
helped this country was timing basically
someone else got hit first Germany was a
bit lucky on one hand and Italy very
unlucky that the corner virus was there
before it reached Germany of
Wesley and that we could learn from
China and from Italy so we had more time
to act as we left five more positive
results came in mostly elderly people so
far Germany has confirmed a lot of cases
but comparatively few debts but here
there is no sense of complacency rather
a fear of what may be about to come